[Music]  ah  get back to it  enemy dropping into the ao  [Applause]  new safe zone  all right  inbound  i'd be able to ambush them  gas is inbound marking a new safe zone  squad member is redeploying  hostile maneuvering  25 remaining  reinforcements are on the way  enemy radar jammer detected in your area  fire an enemy radar jammer in your area  maneuver  get back to it  over  hostile maneuvering  enemy uav active  over  contact front  destination marked  survive until others redeploy  [Music]  recons inbound  uav getting fired lmg  reinforcement  uav is out of fuel returning for  resupply  over  [Applause]  you got gas inbound safe zone relocation  [Applause]  hostile dropping into the area watch the  sky sniper rifle  under fire  [Applause]  good we're all safe  [Applause]  your team is in the top five let's be  the last  [Music]  [Music]  okay  oh  next time  you